Excuse me ma'am, I'm looking for an international phone card.
Okay, we have many you can choose from here.
What country are you planning to call?
Mostly Korea, I want to call my family and friends back home.
Korea, okay, we have a few cards that would work well for you then.
Hmm... they are all too expensive.
Do you have a card called "Asian Express"?
Yes, we have.
It gives the best rates for calling countries in Asia.
What are the rates to call Korea with it?
Let's see... well, it depends if you use a cell phone or a landline.
How much is it if I use a cell phone?
With a cell phone it's six cents a minute.
If you can use a landline, it's only three cents a minute.
Okay, I'll take that one.
How much is it?
Ten dollars, sir.